I have a major major problem with the
Wi-Fi at my apartment where for whatever
reason even though it's not a huge
apartment when I get more than like 10
feet away from my router I all of a
sudden have my phone constantly
disconnecting from the Wi-Fi I figured
out that the phone isn't the problem so
I was excited to try the or be home
Wi-Fi system by Netgear which was
recently sent to me for review and this
is just absolutely fantastic this is a
tri-band system it uses a dedicated
third band which provides the fastest
possible speed between the two or B
units and I don't like spending a lot of
time on this type of thing and this
thing is so easy to set up you basically
have the receiver and then you have the
satellite and it's just so easy to set
up each has its own power source and I
unpacked it you take the receiver and
hook it up directly to your cable modem
and then you just plug in your satellite
where you have the weak Wi-Fi service
and it sets up its own network that you
can connect to each of the source and
satellite units come with their own
power adapters which sort of makes sense
those need power as I mentioned you use
an Ethernet cable to connect the source
receiver to your cable modem and once
that's done all you have to do is take
the satellite unit and plug it in to any
outlet
it also has if instead of Wi-Fi you want
to actually connect more hardwired units
to the satellite you can do that as well
and once you get that plugged in it will
connect to your source receiver and then
I was able to get right on my phone and
no more disconnection problems no more
Wi-Fi issues and as you can see I look
thrilled because no more annoying Wi-Fi
disconnects so I am now going to be this
is my new permanent home Wi-Fi solution
I encourage you to check it out use the
links in the description and thanks to
Netgear for sponsoring this video